so we spoke to Lincoln Reilly a little
less than an hour ago and I started with
the obvious question what was your
reaction to the report by Charlie
Casserly not surprising I mean that's
just in the fact that it's that time of
year you know um people are gonna say
different things I just hate that people
go go out make these comments and you
know you've never even talked to the two
people that have actually coached this
kid he's never even talked to teammates
you know you went on one team said which
said probably smokescreens
no no this draft deal works and all the
different you know back and forth but
this kids a connor was a tremendous
leader for us a tremendous leader a very
aggressive very important they have all
he cares about winning and that really I
think our team took on that personality
without a doubt so he's he you know and
then first process in offense I mean he
just had the you know greatest single
season in the history college football
so I think he could process just fraud
there are a lot of Scouts and even front
office folks who were passing around the
interview I did with Kyler at the Super
Bowl and of course that didn't go well I
don't know if you saw it but or did you
see it I yeah he told me about it he
told me about it after actually what did
he saying well he was in a tough
position you know cuz he hadn't he
hadn't made up his mind yet and he's
such a good kid I mean doesn't want to
lie doesn't want to tell anything wrong
he's uh and and so it was a tough
position for him and so I think that's
you know part of the reason he was ready
to just get this decision made and get
on with it was the kind of constant back
and forth not really being able to talk
about one of the other you know but the
kid understandably in a pretty tough
position when did he talk to you about
making this decision we talked about it
several times
we talked about it I drove down to
Dallas
and then in January early January we
visited upon it for a while with his
with his family and it just kind of
constant contact over the phone and and
you know since then and just you know I
didn't want to be pushy I just wanted to
be there and anyway that that he needed
me and be there to answer questions that
he wanted to ask me so he was he was
throwing with it I could tell you that
he was very thorough with it
he was very trying to be respectful of
both leagues of the rare opportunity
that he has and people will people never
understand what he turned down to play
football I mean this kid loves football
trust me but coach I've seen this before
where these kids get a taste to start
him and then they become something
different I look back on Cuyler Murray
he was a star when he was in high school
and maybe the greatest greatest
quarterback to come out of Texas so
maybe it has he changed personality wise
to you know where he was to you know not
playing to then sitting behind Baker
Heisman Trophy and now maybe the number
one pick and getting a you know first
round dollars from the Oakland A's no no
I mean he if he was gonna change I mean
this would have been the year to do it I
mean all of a sudden you're a kid still
in college playing college football but
you've got a you know multi-million
dollar contract you know that you've
already been paid on some and you get a
lot more coming after that and he was
never any different I mean he handled
you know like I've said before he
handled the whole deal with Baker
getting the extra year you handled that
so well I came in and you know basically
sat for two years and that's a long time
for guys as talented as him but he did
it and did it well and you know was kind
of beloved around here most importantly
by his teammates so now he's his own guy
he is remained as an old guy and I I
just I don't see any of this change in
him he's very confident secure and who
he is but he's a good person and I think
he's absolutely gonna write that way
last time you spoke to Kliff Kingsbury
Oh probably a month ago
what did
talk about I told you congratulations I
think you know the organ order at that
point the last time that we spoke you
know we do we stay in touch contacts we
always years and years but yeah I've
told him congratulations was thorough
for him getting a chance to coach with
the Cardinals and so yeah pretty
exciting stuff when did he ask you how
my day was going do you think he's gonna
reach out after these comments have come
out with the Charlie counseling or has
he already I'm sure we'll have several
people reach out no I haven't talked to
anybody else about him I mean I think I
know caramel with a lot of different
teams at the combine and I've personally
spoken with the majority of the teams
that he met with and every one of them
were glowing in their reports about
Kyler basically the complete opposite
the Charlie threw out there so you know
you're not gonna make everybody happy
that that is true one theme didn't like
him and that's okay that trust me
there's about 25 others out there that
absolutely love them you know what's
amazing is we get caught up in the
prototype quarterback in the NFL that
you got to be six-four six-five and I
said you don't have to be because of new
rules and you know blocking schemes and
we're taking more of college into the
NFL and and so people talked about Baker
Mayfield at six feet like how could you
take him number one now we've gone down
to 510 with Kyler Murray and I'm saying
can they play football not they're guys
who were six five six six six seven
can't play we get caught up in these
prototypes here coach we do and and what
people got to realize is we're not
saying that every 510 or every six
footer can go in there do it I mean do
these two guys are rare breeds I mean
they the guys like this just don't come
along you know every year or every 10
years you know and and they're they're
both get unique skill sets they both
play the position just uniquely well
regardless of how tall they are
they're both damn good and and and you
know in Kyler's case you're talking
about us
skill set that you know that college
football never seen and that the NFL's
never seen I mean you're talking about a
rare rare skill set that you know that
just gets it done and creates so many
problems defensively I mean those
defense coordinators are getting ready
to see their I mean you play a guy like
this it's a it's a different world not
that he's not going to have some some
growing and continuing to improve as a
player that everybody has that coming
into that league but I mean this is a
this is a different animal here well
keep a sense of humor here coach because
I know we're gonna get a lot of people
asking the same questions and do better
in your interviews than maybe Tyler did
with me with Gatorade okay well well it
won't be quite as much fun as getting
interviewed by you we'll put it that way
how's Jalen Hurd's doing he's doing
great
he's doing great yeah neat kid and we
start spring ball actually tomorrow so
it's gonna be a lot of fun to get back
on the field with him with a lot of
these new players that was got in and
try to piece this thing together yeah
you're getting spoiled you got Baker you
got Kyler you got Spencer rattler
waiting in the bullpen and you bring in
jaylen hurts life's pretty good that's
how it should be Oklahoma right and a
pretty good running cubies here so
that's that's always fun you want to go
to the place like this
Thank You coach we appreciate your time
of course damn thank you for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]